Daniel un mensaje de Trump Cómo se ve al
expresidente tiene la fuerza suficiente
para volver
bueno primero Muchas gracias por
invitarme y la realidad es que Donald
Trump está haciendo este anuncio en unos
momentos más débiles desde que bajo las
escaleras de Trump Tower en el 2016 las
elecciones la mitad de término de la
semana pasada lo dejaron una posición
bastante bastante débil y está
aumentando no el tiempo para la
candidatura para tratar de recuperar la
fuerza dentro del partido republicano
Bueno uno de los puntos que llamó la
atención fue la seguridad con la que
dijo que si él estuviera en el poder en
este momento no habría guerra en Ucrania
En qué basa el ex mandatario esta
afirmación
Bueno lo vas en el hecho de que cuando
Donald Trump fue presidente durante sus
cuatro años el Vladimir Putin no atacó
Ucrania bueno no no invadió Ucrania ni
realizó ninguno de sus movimientos
expansivos en Europa cosa que se hizo
Durante los gobiernos de Barack Obama
George y evidentemente Joe entonces
bueno utiliza ese argumento para para
decir eso para firmar ello evidentemente
nunca podremos saber eso porque Donald
Trump no es presidente y es un poco
imposible no saber ese tipo hipotético
Cómo se interpreta este anuncio de su
precandidatura cuando los resultados de
las elecciones de medio término no
fueron los que se esperaban no se
produjo esta ola roja esta marea roja
que esperaban los republicanos
bueno Donald Trump Está tratando de
congelar completamente no el campo de
contrincantes dentro del partido
republicano de plantar su bandera en el
partido y decir yo sigo siendo el
principal candidato en el candidato con
más fuerza el ex presidente de la
persona más popular del partido lo hace
una semana después de unos terribles
resultados para él personalmente las
elecciones en mitad de mandato y también
a sabiendas de que hay posibles
contrincantes como el gobernador de la
Florida ronda santis que ganó una
reelección avasallante en el estado de
la Florida que muchos medios
conservadores y muchas personas del
movimiento conservador que usualmente
han sido
han apoyado al ex presidente Donald
Trump han estado dando señales de que
pueden apoyar a rondesania entonces ante
esta situación Donald Trump ataca
primero por decirlo así no pega primero
para tratar de fortalecer su posición
dentro del partido Bueno ya hemos
escuchado al ex vicepresidente Mike
pence también ya los lo estaba
mencionando ustedes del reelecto
gobernador de la Florida Ronda de santis
que a también quieren luchar por esta
candidatura republicana a la casa blanca
tienen fuerza estas figuras dentro de
Estados Unidos tienen fuerza dentro de
los republicanos como para lograr la
candidatura con un contrincante como
Donald Trump
el gobernador de la Florida es yo creo
que sin dudas el mejor que está el que
está mejor posicionado para enfrentarse
Donald Trump tiene una base de poder que
es un poco independiente a la figura del
ex presidente tiene bastante apoyo
dentro del partido republicano tiene un
récord de éxito de gobierno exitoso en
el estado de la Florida y ganó una
reelección de 60 por con 60% de los
votos en un estado que usualmente es
bastante peleado bastante reñido como el
estado de la Florida Entonces el
gobernador Romeo Santos tiene un buen
chance para desafiar al ex presidente
Trump Mike penn su lado no tiene el por
la misma fuerza dentro del partido
dentro del partido republicano dentro
movimiento conservador como para
desafiar a Donald Trump pero si está en
una posición desde la cual le puede
hacer daño político a Donald Trump una
de las investigaciones que adelanta el
congreso por la toma al Capitolio de Los
Seguidores de Trump no a minado la
confianza en el mandatario
probablemente a minado la confianza
dentro de votantes independientes o
moderados sin embargo dentro de la base
conservadora dentro de la base del
partido republicano esas investigaciones
no han tenido un gran efecto debido que
realmente la base conservadora no era la
audiencia no de esas de esas
investigaciones sin embargo claro para
la base para la población moderada el
botón de moderado Es probable que esta
investigaciones hayan tenido un efecto
se pudo ver no en las elecciones de la
semana pasada bueno y se le puede
achacar de alguna manera al gobierno de
Joe biden o a las políticas que ha
implementado un fortalecimiento de Trump
como posible candidato presidencial ya
como precandidato según lo que está
diciendo que ya envió los documentos a
las autoridades electorales del país
bueno el éxito de Joe el éxito fracaso
de la presidencia Joe biden se va a
basar en si Donald Trump vuelve a la
presidencia en el 2024 o no Si Donald
Trump no logra regresar a la Casa Blanca
en las 24 yo vayan puede decirse a sí
mismo que tuvo una misión cumplida sin
embargo evidentemente si hay un clima
político que favorece al partido
republicano y que favorece a la figura
Donald Trump Entonces sí se podría decir
que fue que la misión principal de Joe
biden que fue distanciar a Trump del
poder político fracasó ahora faltan dos
años recordemos Donald Trump no está en
la mejor posición política actualmente y
cualquier cosa puede pasar